what's up my babies and welcome to
another episode of congratulations
[Music]
hi guys and we
are off and we are off um
and whether you're listening on patreon
or youtube we appreciate you if you're
on youtube thank you for the for the
support and if you're on patreon double
thank you that's patreon.com
crystalia and the uh uh the thing is uh
the episode is longer if you get the
rest of the episodes and um
and you get an extra episode a month but
if not dude just [ __ ] buckle up and
this is another episode of
congratulations and i'm in it dude i got
the [ __ ] best merch that we've ever
made over here at the log cabin make
friends in the comments this has got a
nice design it's embroidered here on my
uh on my left chest right there and um
and it's good man we got it on we got a
tan short sleeve and i actually got them
here dude and we got it this is like qvc
and we got a long pink sleeve make
friends in the comments here
and phil can you toss me the
this is the hoodie it's mint green look
at that i could practically taste it i
can practically taste it but it's mint
green
make friends in the comments just ready
for fall over winter really fall or
winter you know and you can stack them
you know i almost posted um i almost
posted one and my friend was like no you
got to post all three all together and i
said why she said because it's a vibe
because it's a vibe altogether so make
friends in the comments we have the
comment with a link down on the on the
youtube down there so and go ahead and
make friends in those comments
up he died that there's always like
somebody in the qvc that [ __ ] oh he
fell off a ladder okay well he's dead so
let's go let's uh move on to ceramic
angels we've got a plenty of them we've
got plenty of ceramic angels another guy
got stabbed by the angel wing okay let's
bring him
let's bring it
[Music]
all good dude
tried to go trim my beard because i trim
my beard i don't line it up i'm not
[ __ ] you know what i mean i don't
really give a [ __ ]
i'm not like a an armenian guy i'm not a
black guy i'm not one of those white
guys like john b i don't line [ __ ] up i
let it grow and i take it down i let it
grow and i take it down that's what i do
and i let it grow and i was gonna take
it down and i went upstairs to my
bathroom when i even get rid of and one
fire got here to go trim out that
[ __ ] old beard and i dropped it yeah
dude i dropped the [ __ ] shaver and it
broke
is it all good yes it is all good
but my beard's long so you get the
[ __ ] grizzled look you get the
grizzly look dude
and now here come the comments while
chris is looking gray and how but it's
because i didn't trim my beard i didn't
do it and i don't die [ __ ] dude
if i'm dying i'm lying so i'm not doing
that okay so what i'm doing is letting
the beard grow dude i'm 41 and i'm a
tall drink of water and the beard's
going to be long as [ __ ] too
you know
so that's what happened so i didn't get
to [ __ ] dream i really wanted to trim
it and yeah it's itchy is it itchy and
i've had a have i had a headache for
four days yes dude so is think is [ __ ]
uncomfortable yes but is it okay you
know it's fine are we gonna get through
it yes
but it's all
fine my lips are chapped and places
they've never been chapped but it's fine
dude you gotta keep going you gotta let
life [ __ ] hop in and take it for a
ride
man we love it you saw me wearing a
[ __ ] cowboy hat the last episode dude
you s what you know what i mean
so of course my lips are chapped
um
but yeah i'm chilling dude we you know
the past week has been okay it's been
good um
you know stuff still kind of feels like
it's not really
popping yet because the pandemic is
still we're still doing it
you know like uh and it's and it's
really annoying you know i feel like the
whole thing
just uh
like i went to go i was going to my
therapy
and i was early so i was kind of hungry
so i pulled over to go to california
chicken cafe is what it is now everyone
says they love it
everyone says they love it here in la oh
you know what we could get it's that
place you always forget about it's that
place where it's like oh you know we
could get california chicken cafe and
everyone goes like ooh okay i'll have
that and it's not just that it's user
friendly it's that it's the thing it's
the dark horse people think it's the
dark horse right like they'll be like oh
let's go to that sandwich place or let's
get that [ __ ] thing tender greens
let's go to that place where it has the
nice you know um
tofu or whatever the [ __ ] in l.a but
then somebody is like no i don't know
and then somebody mentions california
chicken cafe it's not everywhere but it
is in l.a and people go now that's kind
of the dark horse
i will get the california chicken cafe
thing and what can you get there you
know they like to be [ __ ] raw so
they'll be like yo
you can get the [ __ ] half rotisserie
chicken here we go we just literally
give it to you we give you the the [ __ ]
you want sauces that's a different story
right but nobody [ __ ] only a lunatic
would just like literally get a
rotisserie chicken with no sides
you know like you're some [ __ ] king
at the long end of a table just
right eating the leg of it so i don't do
that so i always get
the uh the chicken wrap which is just
kind of like my move you know and it's
bad
oh it's bad but i keep getting it but
it's bad
and i pride myself on always ordering
the right thing i do i do always like
except for the kill
nothing's worse than the guy you go to a
restaurant with a guy and they just get
the wrong [ __ ] thing right like at at
at denny's you go and you just get like
either like a turkey club or a scramble
or like the moons over miami don't like
saying it but that's what it is right
um but i was at denny's and like
somebody got fish once and you're just
like oh you don't get it dude
you don't get it fish at denny's
ow dude why don't you just drive
straight to the hospital instead
why don't you just sit on the toilet
while you're scarfing it down because
that's where it's going immediately next
it's gonna be like your [ __ ] mouth is
the upper end of your [ __ ] [ __ ]
because you're just gonna swallow it and
and [ __ ] poof
scarf it down every time i say scarf
which is not that often i think of when
i was a kid and my brother had a a a
friend
and my brother was eating lunch when he
was a kid and i guess he wasn't eating
it too quickly my brother takes a long
time to eat for real and his friend said
matt why aren't you scarfing down and i
always think of that dude
and over the years it became why rent
you scarfing down
why rent your scarf in down anyway dude
i went to california chicken cafe got
out of my car they go whoa whoa what are
you doing and i thought well what this
is life
this is life
what do you mean what am i doing when
somebody's just doing something normal
you don't say what are you doing right
if you're just
standing
you don't say hey what are you doing
unless you're trespassing in someone's
backyard but i wasn't
i checked the thing under my feet and it
was a public sidewalk
and i looked up and i was outside
california chicken cafe
and they said what are you doing and i
said what
and they said well what are you doing
and i said i'm trying to order and they
said are you here to pick up i said no
and they said get in your car
and i didn't understand
and i said what's going on and they said
well here in the pandemic and the thing
and we're just because of covid we have
more rules and then i look behind me and
there's a whole [ __ ] it's a lot of
cars like just lined the [ __ ] up
on a street it's not like when you're at
a [ __ ] burger king and it's rolling
around the intercom and [ __ ] and you go
through the parking lot and twists and
turns
like you're in a street from san
francisco this [ __ ] was a normal street
it was like a lincoln boulevard all the
way in venice and cars were just pulling
over there was no drive-through there
were like two workers outside of the
california chicken cafe with masks on
and an ipad and like a podium it looked
like they were about to give a speech
that mattered
and so i said oh get in the car they
said yeah you can just get in the car
and use this qr vc what's the qrc q
[ __ ] code that everyone just you know
they've been around forever but now
because of the pandemic you just take
the picture of it and the menu pops up
on the phone
right
so annoying so i'm at the like go and
order and then scream out from the car
and i'm like okay all right fine
so now i'm like oh i just want a chicken
wrap
and they're like well in the car i get
in the car they had chicken wrap okay
how long is it gonna take and they say
oh it's gonna take like
15 minutes and i'm like all right cool
i'll just chill in my car and then the
lady just walked right out immediately
and gave me the chicken wrap
what's going on dude
first of all we're outside
we're outside
we're outside you're not going to get
covered outside when you're just
standing around not touching anyone
cause the outside dude the germs
die
after they jump out of your mouth
they're not all just like
who else they don't do that dude they
try but they don't make it outside
because they're germs dude right
the wind takes the germs the germs are
like this and the and the wind comes and
jumps like ah [ __ ] it oh and they die
dude because you're outside they're up
in the heavens literally they get
scooped up into the clouds
because germs
it's not dude if you throw a [ __ ]
kleenex at somebody outside that kleenex
hey what the [ __ ] trying to get to the
person but they can't
because
it's outside
and the kleenex barely weighs anything
do you know how much a germ weighs way
less than a kleenex
it's like 1 100th of a kleenex
so we're outside so it's fine because
we're outside
okay but also you got masks on
you got masks on workers so me getting
in the car that's literally like me
being in outer space
that's what's g nobody's getting this
you got masks on and we're outside
so i gotta get in the car and scream out
yeah a chicken wrap that's [ __ ] four
out of ten
can you put how am i and i'm like well i
kind of want extra mayonnaise but i
don't want to make it i'm in like can
you put mech so i don't say and then i
get it it's dry as [ __ ] dude i got the
sahara in my [ __ ] mouth
and always spilling out too dude they
don't make it right they just they don't
wrap it right it spills you take one
bite spills out i'm done dude
i'm done that's it i'm done if you make
a thing where i bite one time and it
splurts out the back
i'm done dude
looks like the [ __ ] back of your of
your rap busted a nut i'm out
oh let me bite
oh [ __ ]
i must just bit into someone's [ __ ]
and that must be their kink because on
the other side of that they busted a nut
but we're outside dude
i saw a guy walking by his lonely while
i was driving by he had a mask on
walking by is lonely
are you giving coven to yourself
just take it off live a little bit dude
everyone [ __ ] walking in outside of
places taking their masks off and
looking like they're [ __ ] like they
just woke up sleeping on a waffle iron
dude
and i'm not political i don't give a
[ __ ] and by the way i got the shot i got
the vaccine call me a sheep if you want
it's not even a [ __ ] it's just like a
dude it's not gonna it's fine dude it's
fine
and then you go inside and you get the
guys who are talking close to you extra
because they want you to know that they
don't believe that kovit and you're just
like dude
just can you back up just in case
yeah yeah yeah but
anyway so california so chicken cat pe
chicken california chicken cafe what the
[ __ ] i don't remember what it's called
but anyway it looks nice and it has some
good stuff and the [ __ ] broccoli the
pasta with the broccoli in it is banging
dude it's so banging
but it's like dude don't get the [ __ ]
chicken wrap man
they don't put the ratios you know what
it is the ratios aren't right the ratios
ain't right dude
and when i go and i eat food the ratio's
got to be goddamn right and i'm good at
ordering too i'm like one of the best
orders around i swear to god too all my
friends know it we go out we go to eat
and they're like what are you going to
get chris and i'm like well um let me
look at the menu oh the chicken sandwich
because it comes with my [ __ ] avocado
and mayonnaise and it's got crispy bacon
on it
oh [ __ ] well you know what never mind
i'm gonna get this they get it and then
they watch me eat it like they're
[ __ ] oliver twist
and i'm like well you should order right
dude i don't know what you're doing
sitting there with the white fish
right
so if you know that i'm like a number
one orderer and i come and i get the
[ __ ]
and then the ratios are all off and the
shit's [ __ ] coming out the backside
then dude what are we talking about here
i'm the [ __ ] steven spielberg of
ordering and it's like [ __ ] i gotta
sit there and watch biodome
so that happened
these places just don't know what to do
during covet i don't want to talk about
covid but i went to phil's coffee too
which by the way let me tell you right
now the phil's coffee fills with a z
don't like it coffee it's good the
phil's coffee is good do it phil's
coffee is [ __ ] good it's really good
i drink it and i go like this now that's
what coffee should be like but why don't
i go there a lot well let's backtrack
let's think about it let's go to the
past episodes of congratulations when
i've talked about coffee what do i like
about coffee i like iced americanos
what's that keyword iced i drink a lot
of iced coffee well what do you do with
an iced coffee well you pour it in a cup
what kind of cup a plastic one yeah is
it see-through mm-hmm
well phyllis what's going on with that
brown cup
i got a question for you what's going on
with that brown cup
you put wet
cold liquid in a brown recyclable cup
what happens to that cup it becomes a
[ __ ] sponge
and it [ __ ] gets all you know what i
mean
get out of here dude if i can't see it
if it's iced and i can't see it it's no
no and then you give me what a paper
straw [ __ ] turtles a paper straw in that
cup no i'm not doing it
but your coffee's banging so i hope you
figure it out and god forbid you give me
a dome lid dude why don't you just
[ __ ] poke my anus
a dome lid and there's no whipped cream
around
whatever i don't wanna but the thing is
so i ordered it and they don't have it i
said hey can i get uh four shots over
ice to say we don't have an espresso
machine and it's like okay you're a
coffee place and they say i said do you
have cold brew and they said we have
cold brew i said good i get cold brew
and they gave me the [ __ ] brown
recyclable cup i don't even know if it
was recyclable or not but it was a brown
cup
dude and i'm there drinking coffee and
i'm trying to make the best of it
and this guy come he's actually
individual this guy comes in and he was
like hey man is that your car oh dude
this is actually hilarious he came in
he's like hey man is that your car out
in the back and i go great someone hit
it
don't do that
he just comes in and says hey is that
your car out in the back and i go oh
yeah did someone hit it and he said oh
no i love it i love it and my friend is
in the market to try and buy one would
you ever wonder about selling it and i
was like well i don't know man you know
i don't know he's like well i love cars
and this and that and then he starts
talking about you know do you mind if i
ask you what i do and i say oh i'm a
comedian he said oh really oh i love
comedy i said yeah and he said yeah yeah
yeah mitch hedberg is my favorite i was
like mitch hedberg was a great comedian
he said ah it's great and he started
talking about joe rogan and that's fine
because everybody talks about joe rogan
every freaking single second of every
day
right ever since two years ago
everyone's talked about joe rogan every
single second of every day of all time
and that's fine but he's mentioning jo
rogan i'm like very cool very cool
that's awesome and then he starts
talking about he says you know who my
one of my favorite comedians are that i
that i wish was uh was more um was more
well known and i said who he said brian
callahan
and i said
huh and he said brian callahan and i
said do you mean brian callan and he
said yup
and i said oh yeah yeah sure yeah he's
great and he said yeah do you know him
and i said
uh
yeah yeah i know him very very well he
said really i said yep he said well you
know what you should do do you know who
brendan schaab is and i said
yeah
and he said you should go on fighter in
the kid
and i was like
hey man
are you [ __ ] mental
how do you know
who they are
and don't know who i am
he said you should ask brendan for
tickets to the next uf's hold up
let me end myself
how the [ __ ]
do you know
who brian callan is and you don't know
who i am dude delia
wake up call
straight up [ __ ]
straight up [ __ ] what are you what
was it gonna say god damn it
i don't know
we're moving down
and i was like yeah yeah okay oh okay i
was like thought he was [ __ ] with me
dude fighter and doom fighter
do fighter in the kid dude i was guest
of the year [ __ ] twice in a row the
first time it was fixed
up
[Music]
brian callahan
ah
says sad
[Music]
so anyway dude
i was like this guy just came in all
[ __ ] sorts of crazy [ __ ]
um
i don't know man
uh but yeah so anyway [ __ ] that
happened and i'm sitting with a paper
straw trying to [ __ ] keep it erect
and [ __ ] but it's all like bucking
around and squeezing my [ __ ] nerf
coffee drink and i'm just like no oh
yeah well yeah no i've done
i've done it before i just
uh oh [ __ ] dude
and so anyway so that happened and then
[ __ ] between that and the california
pizza california chicken cabbage it's
like just figure it out dude
it's figured out
this is the [ __ ] i talk about now though
dude cause cause kristen was like when
we went to [ __ ] uh
uh st louis she heard the podcast
and she was like dude that was great
she's like it's awesome when like you go
and you do [ __ ] and you and then you
talk about [ __ ] on the podcast and i'm
like yeah i get it you know i haven't
been on the road i'm just chilling
um
and the cat and so now i'm talking about
driving the [ __ ] chicken pizza cafe
or where the [ __ ] it's dude i don't know
if you have a place called california
pizza kitchen don't have a place called
california chicken cafe dude
um
but i was [ __ ] uh out one night
i did a spot this was last week i did a
spot and i came home late
and uh
and i came home late and i was coming
home she was like i was texting kristin
and i was like i'll be home in a little
bit it was like 1.
and she was like dude this is so funny
she was like yeah um
she was like i i was like is everything
cool because she was like texting me
like k and yes and
fine and like this is very unlike her
you know and i was like is there
anything cool or what and she was like
well she was like yeah i'm trying not to
text because okay i'm gonna come clean
i'm gonna let you know right now
uh calvin's in the bed with me
and i was like oh son of a [ __ ] she was
trying so hard to do it she tried to
talk me into it so much can we take
kevin out of the crib and [ __ ] sleep
with him in the bed in between us and i
would always say no and the [ __ ]
second i'm home late she goes in scoops
him up comes in and she's like and we
have a perfect little angel boy he
didn't even wake up and i went
wow but now guess what your boy has to
get ready like he's [ __ ] ace ventura
looking for the [ __ ] dolphin in the
movie right i got to be really really
secretive when i come home
and i gotta undress downstairs come up
naked with my [ __ ] boxers on and then
just you know already take my contacts
out on the stairs up
sneak into the door without the [ __ ]
dogs making any noise and not wake
calvin up sneak into bed and just be
like goodnight and then sleep well with
a toddler next to me and not worry about
bumping them
okay so there's a lot of [ __ ] i was like
this [ __ ] but it's cute she
tried to pull a fast one on me and she
did and it's fun and it's cute and you
know me i [ __ ] i'm johnny rolls with
the punches at this point man i've been
to so much therapy i barely get mad i
get mad daily
but i'm johnny rose with the punches but
i still get mad john he still gets mad
but also johnny rolls with the punches
right so i'm rolling with punches but
also still kind of feeling my anger
so i'm like all right all right cool
cool cool i take my phone dimness down
right because i don't even want [ __ ]
brighten it up i got [ __ ] that
text all hours of the night because i'm
friends with comedians
you know i'll get a text at three
o'clock like it's [ __ ] 2 30 p.m
and like hey what's up you know what i
mean by one of my comedian friends hey
dude they'll just ask me some sort of
thing you ever see the [ __ ] episode
of this when that happened at [ __ ] 3
30 a.m why because friends with comics
right that's some [ __ ] you text at noon
or five after work
but um so i get in my uh in the house
and
uh this is so [ __ ] funny i get in
the house
and i show up
into my
into the room and i know calvin and
kristen are in the room
and i already have my contacts out i can
barely see i'm like trying to [ __ ]
you know i opened the door really she's
like i'm gonna get chens because cheng
is always the [ __ ] right she's
like i'm gonna hold chens just come in
and let me know and so
i [ __ ] walk in
i don't hear chens
and i hear cooper
like guard dogging it up all of a sudden
the [ __ ] dog never guarded [ __ ]
and now all of a sudden he's guard
dogging it up roar roar and i hear cow
go
and i'm like [ __ ] we're [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] congratulations we're [ __ ] okay
yeah we're [ __ ]
we've been
straight up
living a beautiful life with this child
just sleeping 13 hours a night from 8
p.m to 9 a.m
and this is gonna start where it's
[ __ ] right right in the terrible twos
this is when terrible twos are literally
gonna start i thought cooper was just
gonna bark the terrible twos into him
and calvin
[Music]
so i get into bed and i get into bed and
calvin does this thing when
he's tired but can't sleep where he's
just like
sucking his thumb and then all of a
sudden he'll post up and just sit up
and then he'll go back down and then
he'll just post up sit up and then go
back down and sometimes he does it until
he falls asleep in the crib and it only
lasts like 10 minutes so i'm doing that
and he's doing it
so he's doing that this time but he's
doing it for
over an hour
and kristen and i you know my heat
level's rising right but but also johnny
rolls with the punches you know so my
heat level's rising but i can't be like
because then calvin would be like our
mama and dad fighting what's going on is
it time to wake up
so i'm just like so i'm like keeping it
cool right
but it's also kind of funny because
calvin's in the middle of the [ __ ]
bed we've never done this before and
he's in his sleep sack and [ __ ] and he
bonked his head once
like it was just all cute
so he i feel a movement i turn around
i'm like maybe my face is distracting or
something i turn around and i you know i
give him my back and then
he i feel something
and then i feel nothing for a while
and i'm like what is he doing you know
he's been too still for a while
and i look over
slowly
and dude is just sitting up
looking right at me just sitting up
looking at me like if i didn't know my
own son i would have thought he was
possessed but he's just sitting
looking at me
and i roll over
to him so now my chest is facing him and
he takes his [ __ ] elbow
leans on my chest like this and i swear
to god it's really dark but i swear he's
holding his own hand it's like he's
looking at me like he owns an
advertisement firm
and he's his elbows on me and it looks
like he's about to say hey how you doing
so he's doing that and i'm just sitting
there while his elbow is on me right and
he's just looking at me we're both
making eye contact for many seconds dude
just not blinking making eye contact
nobody says anything and he's just
staring on me lounging
just looking right at me like he's about
to say hey how you doing and
i just wait i'm like how's this gonna
play out seconds many seconds go by and
then he releases his hand from his other
hand
and then he just takes his finger goes
like this onto me
and this is what he does takes his
finger goes like this
touching right inside my eye okay
it's not hard but he's just touching
right inside my eyes closed my other
one's open but he's pressing my eyelid
right
he does that for about four or five
seconds and then he says
just like this he says
eyeball
[Music]
dude it was [ __ ]
he just is lounging on me
pokes my eyeball and goes eyeball
i laughed so [ __ ] hard then he
started laughing and then it was it that
was it he was awake for another and and
crystal would just be like just give me
five more minutes just give me five more
minutes and now ever since that night he
sees
eyeball eyeball if somebody's [ __ ] if
if a cartoon comes on with big eyes
eyeball eyeball eyeball i ask him where
his eyeballs are he'll go he'll just
start blinking
just poking people's eyes eyeball dude
it was so cute dude
and then we had to put him back in the
crib because like he was like he bonked
his head once and i was like no don't
bonk your head and then he just got up
and just started bonking his head
against the headboard he did it four
times laughing hard as [ __ ] laughing
hard and bonking hard
so i'm like this kid's gonna get brain
damage and [ __ ] we gotta put him in the
crib and so she did she's like you wanna
do it i was like [ __ ] that you took him
out you do it
and she was like okay and then she did
and then he went to sleep and then the
next day he woke up and everything was
great the terrible dudes didn't even
start
so it's all good it's all good
we've been watching love on the spectrum
dude i love these dudes on loving the
spectrum i love these tricks on loving
the spectrum they're all so so sweet
dude the guy's back the guy is back it's
about uh all people who have autism
and dating and you know at first you're
like are they going to be making fun of
them because that's [ __ ] up but they
don't do these people are just lovely
and the guy mike the main guy in it is
just like dude he makes so many thomas
the tank engine faces that it's so
[ __ ] cute like some girl will be like
i don't have a tv and he'll be like
you know
that sucks
and uh but it's so [ __ ] cute and i
think that they're finding love
and i love that dude
everybody just wants love you know
i i wonder uh
like some people just are [ __ ] alone
their whole life that's crazy right
like i have friends that are just like
60 that just never did that
and they're just chilling
and some of these dudes with autism and
these chicks with autism of our mix are
meeting are just meeting up and falling
in love with each other and that's
beautiful they want love so bad it's so
interesting how much they talk about
like i would love this is the one guy
that's just like i would love to have a
girlfriend
i want a girlfriend so bad
like the mom's like what do you think
about like what do you think she'll be
like and he said maybe she'll be a
lovely lady and i'm just like god damn
you know we're doing it all wrong i mean
not you know
you know not me because i have a [ __ ]
great fiance and [ __ ] and a beautiful
son but like you know i did it wrong for
a while but people do it wrong man you
get caught up in all the what do i want
what do i need when you don't see it
when it's right there on your [ __ ]
face dude and all you need is a
beautiful lovely lady
these dudes are showing up bringing
flowers and [ __ ] to the i have you i
have a gift for you
here's flowers with a picnic basket you
ever show up for a [ __ ] date with a
picnic basket dude not me
i haven't even been to a park
i've been to a park but it's like you
know
sandwiches and [ __ ]
just such beautiful like connections
with these people
would you like more yes i would
great that sounds amazing
like just awesome [ __ ] love
you know
so love on this on the spectrum that's
that's out and that's a season
two um
the thing i love about uh
love on the spectrum i should have
[ __ ] said this earlier is um
they're so specific
like the thing about
the thing that's ruining
everything
is
nothing is specific anymore do you
understand what i'm saying
like they're trying to do this with
comedy like people was were talking to
me i saw this very funny sketch on
tiktok the other day and it was comedy
but it was really like off color and
people in the comments were like [ __ ]
that that's not funny this is shitty
this is terrible and it's like
i was thinking about like there's no way
that this would ever be on something
like comedy central or tbs or [ __ ]
fox or whatever the [ __ ] it would just
never be on abc it would never be
anywhere and it really
oh and they kept taking it down off of
tick tock so people were like comedy
doesn't exist anymore like other people
were saying like [ __ ] this it's funny
comedy doesn't even exist anymore and it
does exist it's just harder to find it's
on the internet right there are people
out there that are really doing comedy
but it's harder to find you know it's
not on comedy central because they're
[ __ ] owned by viacom and viacom is
like well let's not mention anything
that's off color
okay and i get that and that doesn't
mean it can't be funny there's funny
[ __ ] on comedy central but there's a lot
of stuff that falls through the cracks
that is funny because it's offensive and
they won't put it on when whereas 20
years ago they would have look at the
dave chappelle show look at that kind of
[ __ ] look at in living color look at all
the other shows that have been on that
were [ __ ] hilarious that would just
never be on the [ __ ] show never be on
tv anymore but comedy does exist and
it's in the depths of the internet and
sometimes it gets kicked off as [ __ ]
like tik tok instagram or whatever the
[ __ ] because there's too much youtube
seems to still have it thank you your
boy but it's there somewhere it's not
only relegated to like 8chan or the dark
web yet it's not it might be but it's
not it exists
but
my point is that [ __ ] is specific
and i love specific [ __ ] and i love when
[ __ ] is specific because
i was talking about this with uh kristen
she loves target and she's like why do
you hate target so much and i said
because you can go there and just get
lost you don't go there for a specific
thing you go i said why do you go to
target she's like well i go and i
[ __ ] look i go to the different thing
i shop around no that's it i don't want
to go there i want to go for a thing
right radio shack that existed you would
go for a vcr noah's bagels i know what
i'm getting right
starbucks used to be specific now it's
mcdonald's
they've got an egg mcmuffin they've got
different drinks you can get [ __ ]
snacks you can get sandwiches no i want
to go to a place that bangs out the
[ __ ] coffee that's what i want
don't give me other extra [ __ ] i get it
you do it because you want your pockets
all lumped up i get it ceo
but when you're not specific you're
failing at all of the things
it's like a jack of all trades master of
none you go to target you go to
walgreens you go to walmart you go to
all these places
but what are the [ __ ] the bodega shops
the mom and pop shops right boot barn
you go you get boots
pretty soon you're gonna go to a [ __ ]
boot barn and they're gonna be like oh
by the way did you want how did you want
your sandwich and you're like what's
going on they're like well we just sell
everything because it's [ __ ] largely
profitable
everything is becoming the same thing
instagram it's becoming tick tock tick
tock's becoming snapchat i mean dude
they got [ __ ] instagram is literally
facebook now
everything is becoming the same thing
there's nothing to distinguish other
[ __ ] from other [ __ ] as a matter of fact
black people white people asians they're
all the [ __ ] they're all the [ __ ]
they're all the [ __ ]
everyone's [ __ ] and they're all gonna
be mixed race everything's becoming the
same thing everything is becoming the
same [ __ ] thing pretty soon we're
gonna have only mixed race people
shopping at every place and every place
is gonna be mcdonald's that's what it's
gonna be
and there's nothing we can do to fight
that there will still be those
outsiders those outliers rather that are
just
searching for that [ __ ] real comedy
that one guy behind a microphone
screaming about some [ __ ]
that either used to be
or that he's trying to hold on to this
thought that he's trying to hold on to
but we're just [ __ ] doomed dude
that's it
there's a [ __ ] uh a place that sells
uh uh umami burger they sell [ __ ]
sushi and burgers dude
they sell sushi and burgers
pick one and knock it out the park
guess what if you sell sushi and burgers
guess what are two things that suck in
your restaurant
correct
you got it right i don't even have to
say it
the chinese started with their [ __ ]
chinese food and donuts dude
in la canada when i was coming up on the
[ __ ] mean streets of la canada
dude i drive by every day i see chinese
food and donuts and i would think wow
who the [ __ ] would go there guess what
everybody and now every place is the
same
dude you can buy meatballs at ikea
case import
it's all the same thing dude when there
wasn't the internet and i'm not [ __ ]
being the guy that's like i wish we were
going back to old times i don't even
wish that it's happening the way it's
going to happen i'm not the guy look i
do want to get a log cabin eventually
with my cult and just grow and build out
there but it's not like we're not gonna
have iphones
it's not like we're gonna pop into a
[ __ ] coffee bean and tea leaf there's
one gonna be right next door that we
built as well
but it's true man everything's becoming
the same thing dude
when i go to the mall i go to the mall
because i'm going to a specific store in
the mall i don't go to the mall
right
that's it
you know
it's happening with video games what's
happening with everything man i've been
on twitch a lot you know uh flex avenue
follow me there but we have fun man i'm
on red dead redemption i like that game
it's real specific but it's also just
like every other open world game
you know you're out there in [ __ ]
open world you're just wandering around
this is just real life basically now not
only is [ __ ] life gonna be everything
in life gonna be like everything but now
everything in video games in the virtual
world is gonna be like real life
everything is the [ __ ] same
real comedy's out there i don't like
that i don't like what all your kids
this whole thing like oh you can't say
this anymore you can't say that anymore
oh [ __ ] that's not it's that's not
funny anymore you can say whatever you
want there's just enough people out
there that are going to be so annoying
to you about how you shouldn't say it
because they're people with voices too
honestly just [ __ ] everyone everyone
just shut up everyone who has an opinion
stop it
just stop it
you don't need to
right do you have to [ __ ] sound off
about everything
i guess you do i guess you do
i guess you [ __ ] do man
you know
i don't know people take it so seriously
that's what it is you know like i was
bitching a moaning about the [ __ ] st
louis uh
hotel
and i was like nobody go there but i was
just joking i don't care [ __ ] go if
you want it's got an aquarium you know
you can pet the stingrays
calvin did it and people were like oh
he's trying to [ __ ] call out the
thing it's like bro dude shut the [ __ ]
now this guy's on me
nobody can do anything that's why i just
shut it down dude i don't even [ __ ]
have some of the social media outlets
anymore because i just don't want to
[ __ ] look i almost looked at [ __ ]
twitter the other day just for shits and
giggles i wanted to see what was
trending and i just guessed and i was
probably right dude i was probably right
you know it's probably [ __ ] something
joe rogan said something that [ __ ] uh
uh uh something about gallery potito and
then it was probably something else
somebody else got arrested or something
that's all that's all it was and then
something that was it was probably
whatever day it was national [ __ ]
computer day or whatever the hell it was
i'm done dude
i used to not understand why people
would want to unplug because it took us
so many years to build this [ __ ] but bro
i get it now man
i get it now you just want to unplug
sometimes everyone's addicted to their
phones and i am too
calvin grabbed his [ __ ] uh calvin
grabbed this um
what are you called
i'm we're at the point where we're
trying to guess at what he means always
like sometimes we can hear it
like what he's saying and like make it
out like like
like okay like take this like okay truck
and shark those don't sound alike but to
him truck is tuck and shark is [ __ ]
there's a difference there okay
i can tell cause i'm his dad and by the
way you wouldn't even be able to tell if
he was just like tuck and there were no
trucks around and you didn't know him
because you'd be like i don't know what
he's saying but i do it's truck because
he sees a truck usually and i'll go tuck
right
but today but he also hears words that
are not just by me or kristin they'll be
like on tv or something like that and
his mom uses the [ __ ] apple tv
kristen uses the apple tv thing to be
like search holiday decor she'll do it
like that you know and then it'll come
up and she'll just click on it
and i don't know what she said the other
day but he heard something on tv and he
was going goku
goku
goku and he was [ __ ] he had the thing
and kristen was in her [ __ ] zoom
class in the other room and he was just
like goku
coco coco with the [ __ ] apple remote
just go go screaming in the apple remote
and i'm like dude i don't know what
you're saying and he's like goku and
he's just screaming crying goku like to
me
and i [ __ ] pop my head and i'm like
babe what the [ __ ] does goku mean and
she's like what and i said what does
goku mean did you show him something
about goku and she's like i don't have a
clue and i'm like i don't know what the
[ __ ] he's saying he's just screaming
crying about goku he's like well can you
get him to stop i'm like in the middle
of school and it's really distracting
and i'm like well did you [ __ ] show
him goku or not and she's like no so i'm
like okay so i'm like i don't know what
he's saying and then when she got out of
the room we were like oh [ __ ] i think he
means coco coco melanie's watching this
[ __ ] creepy ass show coco melon
like the kid
will like
it's like so creepy i think it's on
netflix
but it's always like [ __ ] i am the
kid and you are the stupid dumb parent
and the kids just like grabbing mustard
and he takes the mustard and the dad's
like oh you'll do it son and they'll
grab the mustard and it'll just go
[ __ ]
and squeeze all over the dad's chest
and the dad's like oops i can't handle
the mustard
and the kids and the mom's like daddy
can't handle them because the dad's
always the dumbest one in the family
because if not then your [ __ ] show's
problematic right in 2021 even kids like
you gotta teach like every commercial
the dad's like well i don't know what
i'm doing and then he shits on the
[ __ ] linoleum floor and the mom's
like use glad
and the kid's like dad
well i can't have my friends over
tonight i guess
why and he's just like why
just with two missing teeth
and the kid's like because you [ __ ] all
over the linoleum floor
glad
we're tougher on st on [ __ ] on take
if you have to take out the trash we're
tougher now
every [ __ ] commercial
the dad will come in hey guys
how do you make it how do you make the
how do you make life work
and they're like
you need to be on a diet you fat [ __ ]
all right what do i what did i do
slim fast
give us
give us one week if you're not a man and
if you're a dad it'll take you nine
months because you're [ __ ] dumb slim
fast
hello
pretty soon there's just going to be a
commercial it's just going gonna be a
[ __ ] dad
a fat [ __ ] dad and he's just gonna be
pissing and [ __ ] in like a [ __ ]
museum
and someone's gonna be like hey and
they're gonna arrest him and it's gonna
be like tied
[Laughter]
tougher on stains
sorry
oh man
nothing's for dads dude dads are just
dumb as [ __ ]
it's so hot right now to make fun of
dads
i got a [ __ ] son i'm a dad
i guess i'm dumb as [ __ ] too though [ __ ]
it
you know i don't know where [ __ ] is
i ask kristin where things are all the
time she tells me and then i ask again i
guess whatever dude whatever is it
relatable i don't know man i don't even
give a [ __ ] i don't know man like i was
i did a joke like i was going into the
shower and kristen was in the back was
in the in the bathroom watching me
or we were just having a conversation i
was creepy but we were having a
conversation and she was and i was like
walking in the bathroom and walking into
the shower and she and i was like hey
could you get me some soap and she was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me and i
was like what she was like you weren't
even in the shower yet and you asked for
a soap because you ran out why don't you
get the soap first before you go into
the shower i was like i don't know i was
already on my way in and i started
laughing and she started laughing i was
like well i don't even know where the
soap is she's like yes you [ __ ] do
and i was like no i don't she was like
where do you think it is and i looked
under my sink and sure enough the
[ __ ] soap was right there but like
that's where i am that's the level of
person i am i think i don't know where
it is and also i'm on my way already so
can you grab it
that's the kind of guy i am and i think
that that's just dad [ __ ]
you know and i was like well babe i
don't know man i just i knew you knew
where it was
and like i just didn't know where it was
and i i just i figured you were in the
bathroom it wouldn't be that big of a
deal
oh and then i was like and then babe you
got dude she does this thing where she
just uses my toothbrush dude she just
uses it i've got the pink and purple
[ __ ] toothbrush i've told you the
problem is dude she'll be like hey which
toothbrush is yours and i'll be like the
pink and purple one so don't use it
she'll have a blue one right they're
both cold colors but whatever it doesn't
matter i got the pink and purple one
she's got the blue one so she's using
the blue one and i'm using the
pick-a-purpose every time i'm using the
pick-up purple one and then in like
three days she'll come up with a new
toothbrush and it'll be like [ __ ]
purple and orange and i'm like it's too
close
so she'll get rid of her [ __ ] blue
one and now there's a purple and orange
one and a purple and pink one and sure
as [ __ ] the next week i look and the
toothbrush just switched places and i'm
and now i'm sick i'm guessing myself i'm
like is mine the orange one or not i
feel them and then the orange one is
like it feels a little wet she got up
before i did maybe she used the orange
one i'll use the pink one and i don't
even remember that the pink one was mine
originally in the first place so i said
sweetheart you gotta stop using my
toothbrush and she was like well babe i
don't know which one it is you always
get a new toothbrush and i said i'm
always going to do it because you always
end up using all of them
i'm trying to she's like why does it
matter and i was like it just does dude
and she's like we both drink out of the
same stuff we kiss what the [ __ ] what's
that matter i was like i know it's just
gross to me for some reason i know we're
basically the same person but it's just
gross don't use my toothbrush and she
was like well you know
why it's not important and i said it's
important to me and she said of course
she did the thing that she of course
she's going to do which i knew it was
coming it was locked and loaded but she
said well why are the things that are
important to me
you don't do like keeping the house tidy
i said keep it a house tight he's
[ __ ] hard and that was my point but
switching toothbrushes isn't hard and
she was like exactly it's hard so i have
to do it you [ __ ] leave this [ __ ] all
around and it's hard and you make me do
it and ah she [ __ ] got me god damn
[ __ ] ass
she got me
we're both lawyers and she got me
she just goes i rest my case she might
as well said i can rest my case dude
i used her tooth i used the toothbrush
again well you know it's like and then i
was like i'm gonna go out
i'm gonna go out this is the kind of guy
i am i'm gonna go out and i'm gonna get
a toothbrush i'm gonna show her i'm
gonna show her the business i'm gonna
give her the [ __ ] business i'm gonna
go out i'm gonna get [ __ ] 10
toothbrushes i'm going to say they're
all mine and i'm going to write my
[ __ ] name on them i'm going to ban
them all together they're all going to
be mine and you can't have one you can't
have one and she was going to be you
know on the defense about it i knew it
was when i came home i was going to say
these are my ten two prizes you can't
have one and i knew she was gonna be
like okay cool fine i'll just use mine
it doesn't matter to me and then i knew
the day was gonna come where she was
gonna be like i can't find my toothbrush
can i use one of your ten and i couldn't
wait for that day
i couldn't wait for that day because i
was gonna be like no because do you
remember and she was gonna be like well
that's not really what you said and i
was gonna pull up a recording because i
was gonna record it anyway and i was
gonna record the conversation i'm gonna
say what about this conversation that we
had there you admitted that you weren't
gonna take one of my 10 toothbrushes and
i had the whole [ __ ] plan and i went
out and i got a coffee and i was gonna
go to write it afterwards and i forgot i
forgot that's the kind of guy i am i
forgot i forgot so now i still have the
[ __ ] toothbrushes in those things
they're both switched around under both
hers and i gotta brush my teeth with her
and i toothbrush we have a freaking
community toothbrush
great we're a family and we have [ __ ]
three toothbrushes me calvin's and hers
and she's used calvin's too and we've
all used each of our three toothbrushes
so that's the kind of i [ __ ] just
nothing is important and everything is
important that's the thing
please don't use my toothbrush it really
means something to me oh does it yeah
well then i'm going to go do that thing
i'm going to go to write it get 10
toothbrushes went and got coffee forgot
to do it came home so everything is
important and nothing is important
and that's the kind of [ __ ] thing it
is that's the kind of life i live
i'm just a dumb dad i'm basically that
dad in that glad commercial that comes
in shits on the floor and everyone's
just like
dad
you just let diarrhea leak down your
[ __ ] calves
sorry
i'm loving it
i'm a dad
come on down to mcdonald's it doesn't
matter that you're a dad with a leaky
anus and [ __ ] let diarrhea [ __ ] all
over your calves and get in your socks
we've got a new quarter pounder for half
the price come on in da da da da
i leaked all over dad i'm loving it
i could sing dude
hove
god i wish jay-z did that when he [ __ ]
dude isn't it so funny to think you know
how you ever have one of those [ __ ]
number twos where you're just like
and you can't help it dude everyone's
done that jay-z's done it how funny is
that jay's been jay-z's been on the
toilet literally like this before
in the past [ __ ] few years like 40
year old jay-z's literally been on the
toilet just like
you know what i mean just like oh like
like couldn't help but just body
convulsing with his [ __ ] aim and he's
just like
so hard that he's almost throwing up and
that's the dude that was that was like
[ __ ] jumped out like yeah who the
[ __ ] you wit and he's been on the toilet
just like
rick ross has been on the toilet just
like
you know
just being on the toilet so hard just in
his [ __ ] palace just
with a sword outside of the room just
like
that's so funny dude
everyone's always [ __ ]
everyone's always [ __ ] [ __ ] and fell
down and tripped too you know that's why
there's no batman in real life that's
why there's no batman you know that
because people trip and fall and take
shits and diarrheas and [ __ ] batman
can't do that that's the only reason why
there's no batman not because it's too
hard to [ __ ] thwart all of the
villains because you need to trip and
fall and do dookie sometimes that's why
that wouldn't be the same if it was
something
[Music]
joker just running away with all the
loot and batman just still just [ __ ]
still just half the suit on with the
mask off just
still kind of bruce wayne not even
batman yet i'll be right there
penguin just gassing everybody and
batman's just straight up gas in his
[ __ ] own
dantd
oh god they picked the right the
scarecrow picked the right time to make
the city afraid
bruce wayne's kids dad
but everybody
kings and queens and [ __ ] presidents
alike
everyone's just sat on that toilet just
grumping
just taking a [ __ ] grump
you know they say
as a comedian like picture the crowd
naked so you don't get nervous and they
it's like dude i just
everyone's [ __ ] grumped
i'm not talking about [ __ ] and i'm
talking about grumping when you're
[ __ ] okay this is so gross you know
whatever
i'm just being so disrespectful looking
at my texts right now whatever i do what
i want dude i love you guys i love you
guys and we're a cult dude that's it
period we are a cult
make friends in the comments dude that's
it period
we're a [ __ ] cult and i love it
and you su dude how about this you
support me i [ __ ] support you dude i
love it
i guess that's it
we started like five minutes in but it's
109 so i guess that's it dude
that's it right
um
i had a good time sensational come join
us on flex avenue we play video games
i'm on red dead redemption it's fun
patreon.comcrystalia uh it's just been
[ __ ] firing on all syllables really
you know
we've been having a good time
and uh
open the info here under the youtube
video for like merch to get this uh make
friends in the comments [ __ ] we got the
uh
what do you call it go meet him and
sometimes stay out
and uh oh i saw the guy again out there
uh with that same shirt on i kind of
tried to take a video of it i don't want
to like show his face and [ __ ] but um i
do have that i'm going to show you that
the actual the the inception of that
[ __ ] idea wow i can't believe i'm
talking like that like i'm [ __ ] elon
musk it was a goddamn stupid bit um so
anyway dude hey guys that's the end of
the episode uh if you want to catch the
rest of the episode
go on over to our patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
and uh we've got an extra episode a
month we've got other segments like we
do a thing called review mode where it's
me doing some extra content
and also there's behind the scenes stuff
and there's
merch drops there's all sorts of stuff
that uh
the public not on patreon gets but uh
you can sign up today or you don't have
to you know you could just enjoy the
podcast on youtube but you're not
getting the full experience thanks a lot
guys and appreciate your support
[Music]
congratulations
[Laughter]
the worst
the worst slugging ever
[Laughter]